♪ ♪
>> Sean: ANOTHER NUMBER OF
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES HAVE
ALREADY THROWN THEIR HAT INTO
THE RING, TURNING INTO A CONTEST
OF WHO CAN BE THE MOST RADICAL.
HERE WITH REACTION, THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION, THE SONS
PRESIDENT, THE BABY IS GETTING
SO BIG, SO FAST.
>> GOOD LITTLE BOY.
>> Sean: LOVE THE PICTURE IN
THE OVAL OFFICE, YOU JUST SAW
WHAT WE PLAYED, YOU CANNOT HAVE
THE CHOICE OF HEALTH CARE, WE
ARE GOING TO STOP DRILLING
NATURAL GAS, ALL OF THE
RESOURCES, ALL OF THE JOBS WITH
IT, THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE
ECONOMY, I AM LISTENING AND
SAYING THAT THIS IS GREAT FOR
YOUR FATHER.
>> DOES NOT MAKE ANY SENSE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOW THE PARTY
OF JFK, THEY HAVE BECOME SO
RADICALIZED.
DO YOU WANT 70% TAXES?
YOU LOOK AT KAMALA HARRIS, SHE
ALWAYS GOES AFTER, SHE CALLS HIM
THE KKK, YOU REMEMBER THAT
FAMOUS INTERVIEW.
>> Sean: I PLAYED IT LAST
NIGHT, THEY DO NOT WANT LAW AND
ORDER, THEY WANT BUSINESSES OUT
OF THE COUNTRY, NOT LETTING
ANYBODY IN THE COUNTRY, THEY
WANT TO BANKRUPT US TO SYSTEM,
FREE HEALTH CARE FOR ALL, THEY
WENT TO ELIMINATE PRIVATE
HEALTH CARE.
SHE HAD WALKED ABOUT THAT
COMMENT BECAUSE IT WAS SO
RIDICULOUS, HOW DO YOU PAY FOR
THIS STUFF?
WE WOULD BE VENEZUELAN SO MANY
OTHER COUNTRIES, IT DOES NOT
WORK, THAT'S NOT WHAT AMERICA IS
ABOUT, IT IS ABOUT HARDWORKING
PEOPLE IN CAPITALISM.
IT IS THE GREATEST COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD, BECAUSE PEOPLE WORK
FOR THAT.
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
>> Sean: ELIZABETH WARREN ONCE
ANOTHER BITE OF THE APPLE AFTER
YOU PAY ALL OF YOUR TAXES.
>> IT IS INSANE.
AND THEY HAVE BECOME SO
RADICALIZED.
IT IS NOT GOING TO WORK.
THEY BECOME CRAZY.
THE MESSAGE DOES NOT MAKE SENSE
ANYMORE.
IT'S ALMOST ANTI-AMERICAN.
TOTALLY OPEN BORDERS.
>> Sean: NOT THE VALUES THAT
HAS GROWN US INTO THE ENVY OF
THE WORLD.
>> WE HAVE THE GREATEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD, ONE OF THE SAFEST
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD, A
MILITARY THAT IS TOTALLY
REBUILT, AND MANUFACTURERS
COMING BACK, LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT.
GROUPS THAT HAD BIG EMPLOYMENT
PROBLEMS, AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANICS, ET CETERA, ALL TIME
UNEMPLOYMENT LOWS.
THE COUNTRY IS DOING AWESOME.
AND ALL THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IS
ATTACK HIM.
THEY DO NOT WANT HIM TO    TO TO
SUCCEED AT ANYTHING.
AT LEAST HE HAS DONE SUCH A DAMN
GOOD JOB, THEY DO NOT WANT HIM
TO SUCCEED AT ANYTHING.
AND TODAY HAVE BECOME THE PARTY
OF DESTRUCTION, NONSENSE, AND
INVESTIGATIONS, BECAUSE THEY
HAVE NOTHING ELSE.
>> Sean: I'VE KNOWN YOUR DAD
FOR OVER A COUPLE OF DECADES.
>> GREATEST GUY IN THE WORLD.
A >> Sean: HE IS A GREAT GUY,
PERSONALITY WISE IF PEOPLE KNEW
THE GUY THAT I KNEW.
HERE'S A FUNNY THING, THERE IS A
SHIFT IN STRATEGY, SHUTDOWN,
THEY WILL NOT EVEN TALK TO ME.
I WILL GIVE YOU THREE WEEKS, DO
YOUR JOB, I AM 99% CERTAIN, AND
I HAVE NO INSIDE KNOWLEDGE AT
ALL, I AM 99% CERTAIN THAT WHEN
THEY CANNOT DO A DEAL AND CANNOT
DO THEIR JOB, YOUR FATHER WILL
GO TO PLAN B, THAT MEANS THEY
GET NO DACA, NO DREAMER HELP,
NONE OF THE THINGS THAT THEY SAY
THEY WANTED, AND THEY CAN SHOP
IT, DO YOU JUDGE SHOPPING AND GO
TO THE NINTH CIRCUIT, AS
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, STOPPING
HEROIN, CARTELS, GANG MEMBERS,
AND SOME THAT WILL COMMIT A
CRIME, NOT THE 98%, BUT THE 2%,
THAT IS HIS JOB.
THAT IS WHAT HE SWORE TO UPHOLD
TO KEEP THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SAFE.
>> THAT'S WHY THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ELECTED HIM, BECAUSE HE
IS A FIGHTER FOR WHAT IS RIGHT
AND WRONG, AND YOU HEAR
CHUCK SCHUMER AND NANCY PELOSI,
ONE KNOWN NEGOTIATION, BUT WE
WILL ONLY NEGOTIATE WHEN
GOVERNMENT IS OPEN.
BUT THEN THEY DON'T ACTUALLY
COME OUT AND NEGOTIATE, AND THEN
YOU HAVE NANCY PELOSI, WELL, I
WILL GIVE YOU $1 TOWARDS YOUR
WALL, BUT LET'S SPEND $5 MILLION
ON DRONES TO FLY OVER THE
SOUTHERN BORDER THAT WILL NOT BE
EFFECTIVE AT ALL.
WHEN CAN WE START USING SOME
COMMON SENSE IN THE COUNTRY?
WHEN CAN YOU STOP THE DRUGS AND
MS-13, HAD PEOPLE COME INTO THE
SYSTEM LEGALLY?
WE WANT IMMIGRATION, BUT WE WANT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
WE WANT THEM TO COME IN THE
RIGHT WAY.
>> Sean: HERE IS WHERE YOUR
DAD IS FIGHTING FOR, AGAINST
DRUGS, HUMAN TRAFFICKING, DRUG
TRAFFICKING, LIFE AND DEATH
ISSUES FOR AMERICANS, ANGEL MOMS
AND DADS.
I'VE INTERVIEWED A NUMBER OF
THEM.
HE IS FIGHTING FOR SECURITY, AND
SAFETY OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHAT WAS NANCY AND CHUCK
FIGHTING FOR?
>> ALL THEY ARE FIGHTING FOR IS
TO MAKE SURE THAT HE DOES NOT
ACHIEVE THE AGENDA THAT HE
PROMISED TO ACHIEVE.
THEY REALIZE THAT HE IS WINNING
ON EVERYTHING ELSE.
SO HOW CAN WE OBSTRUCT THAT
MESSAGE?
YOU SEE THAT ANGLE?
I RAN INTO ONE, THEY LOST A
CHILD A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO, AND
I REMEMBER HER IN THE PICTURE.
>> Sean: 4,000 HOMICIDES.
>> THIS IS WHAT WE ARE FIGHTING
FOR, AS WELL AS HAVING A COUNTRY
AND HAVING LAWS, AND YOU SEE
WHAT IS IN THE IMMIGRATION
PROBLEM, SUMMONING COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD.
>> Sean: YOU AGREE WITH ME,
ONE TO OPEN UP
THE GOVERNMENT.
AND LET'S SEE, IF THEY WERE
ACTUALLY BEING TRUTHFUL, ONCE
THE GOVERNMENT WAS REOPENED THAT
THEY WOULD COME TO THE TABLE AND
NEGOTIATE SOMETHING THERE.
AND IF THEY DON'T TO DECLARE THE
EMERGENCY, BUILD A WALL WITH THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY WANT, AND THEN REDOUBLE
YOUR EFFORTS ON LEGAL
IMMIGRATION, GET GREAT PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY, BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT AMERICA WANTS AND NEEDS AND
QUITE FRANKLY, OUR ECONOMY
NEEDS.
BECAUSE UNEMPLOYMENT IS SO LOW
THAT WE NEED THOSE JOBS, BUT DO
IT LEGALLY.
>> Sean: HE KEEPS ALL OF THE
PROMISES, SOME PEOPLE, WHAT HAVE
YOU DONE IN THE LAST 30 SECONDS,
BUT SWITCHING STRATEGIES, HE
WILL NOT STOP.
I THINK THAT I KNOW I'M PRETTY
WELL, HE HAS THAT TENACIOUS, I